du Québec. Elle juge que la
régie du bâtiment n'en fait pas
assez, n'est pas assez sévère.
Sébastien Desrosiers.
- Des dizaines de mises
en chantier sont prévues
cette année, au Québec.
Mais votre entrepreneur
a-t-il les compétences requises
pour effectuer les travaux?
GUYLAINE LECLERC
vérificatrice générale du Québec
- Selon la loi sur le bâtiment,
une licence de la RBQ
devrait être gage de qualité
et de confiance.
- Dans son rapport,
la vérificatrice générale
affirme que la RBQ,
la Régie du bâtiment du Québec,
ne prend pas les moyens
appropriés pour vérifier les
compétences des entrepreneurs
à qui elle accorde des licences.
- Nous avons d'abord constaté
que la stratégie et les moyens
mis en oeuvre par la Régie
du bâtiment pour s'assurer des
compétences des entrepreneurs
sont insuffisants.
- En fait, aucune évaluation
des compétences en exécution
de travaux de construction
n'est requise pour certains
entrepreneurs spécialisés
dont l'excavation et
le terrassement, ou les portes
et fenêtres, par exemple,
et les plaintes sont nombreuses.
MARC-ANDRÉ HARNOIS, DG Ass. des
consomm. qualité construction
- Vous avez un toit qui coule?
Ça peut faire beaucoup de dégât,
surtout quand ça coule pas
beaucoup, derrière les murs,
ça peut prendre longtemps
avant qu'on s'en rende compte,
et quand on s'en rend compte,
il y a de la moisissure...
SYLVAIN LAMOTHE, porte-parole,
Régie du bâtiment du Québec
- Y'a énormément de travail
qui a été fait. La Régie
n'est pas parfaite.
- La Régie promet des actions.
La majorité des entrepreneurs
seront par exemple soumis
à de la formation obligatoire
continue dès l'an prochain
pour garder leur licence.
Jusqu'ici ils n'étaient pas
obligés de mettre à jour
leurs connaissances.
- On veut avoir confiance et ça
doit être ainsi, tout à fait.
- On n'a pas lu le même rapport.
- Celui qui défend les
consommateurs insiste :
il ne faut pas se fier
uniquement à la licence.
- En fait, la meilleure source,
ça reste les références.
Si vous connaissez quelqu'un
de confiance qui a eu une bonne
expérience avec un entrepreneur,
ça, ça vaut de l'or.
- La Régie du bâtiment joue
un rôle essentiel dans
un secteur clé de l'économie.
En 2019, l'industrie de
la construction représentait
53 milliards $ de dépenses
d'investissements.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, M